Gentlemen, this is
the strength test.
The test is strength and
durability of your edge
as well as the overall
construction of your knives.
I'm going to baton your knives
through these slate tiles
twice.
Matthew, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Oh yeah.
All right, let's do it.
I am nervous.
The cracks are still
on my head, and I
don't want my knife to fail.
Well, Matthew, first things
first, your edge held up very
well, no wiggling, no chipping.
The handle, little
bit on the small side.
Right up here where the
finger rail is, it's square
and it's a little bit bitey.
Overall, it held up nicely.
Well done.
- Thank you.
Wade, you're up next.
You ready?
Yeah, I suppose.
I'm worried going into testing.
I just hope my blade is
usable, it's testable.
I just have no
confidence right now.
Well Wade, your edge
held up very well.
It's a bit obtuse for me.
It's more like an ax edge
than a slicing knife.
There is some gapping here where
the shoulders meet the guard.
But, overall, well done.
Thank you, sir.
Christoph, you're up.
All right.
You ready?
Break that puppy.
I don't want to break it.
Oh, come on.
All right, fine,
I'll break it.
I feel a little bit nervous.
Tile, not very good for edges.
Well Christoph, out here where
it was resting on the tile,
your edge held up very well.
But when I hit
it, it put a roll.
You can hear it--
Yeah.
--on the edge here.
And I do like the
shape of your handle.
It's a very classic design.
Overall, it held up very well.
All right, gentlemen,
now that we brutalized
your blades in
our strength test,
it's time for the
sharpness test.
I'll deliver two blows to this
conveyor belt with your blade.
Now a sharp blade
should have no problem.
All right, Matthew, you're up.
You ready?
Let' do it.
HOST: OK.
All right, Matthew,
the blade's sharp.
Second cut, it
blew right through.
The first cut when I hit this
blade just rolled in my hand.
For me, there's not enough
handle to the blade.
But the blade's sharp.
It's definitely a cutter.
It went through
the belt. Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Wade, you ready?
I suppose.
That was not a threat.
I'm worried about the
handle busting through,
something loose coming undone.
The anticipation is grueling.
I have to hold my arm to
keep my hands from shaking.
So Wade, first off, I really
like the shape of your handle.
It fits my hand really nicely.
Good chopping edge.
I could take a tree
down with this easy.
But as far as cutting
this conveyor belt,
it's just not cutting.
All right, Christoph,
let's do it.
Well, I really like the
design of your knife.
Your handle feels wonderful.
I like that simple grip.
The style of your
blade is great.
I just wish it had
more of an edge on it.
I can run my finger
along your edge
without fear of cutting myself.
An edge like that's
just not going
to cut this kind of material.
I'm sitting in the
same spot as Christoph.
He has some flaws.
I just think mine are more.